en attendant évidemment le discours du
futur président ce ministre mes chers
collègues
mesdames et messieurs c'est pour moi un
grand honneur de présider la séance
d'ouverture de la session parlementaire
2000 sera 2021 le privilège de l'âge
m'autorise à m'exprimer devant vous en
cette circonstance et j'y suis
profondément sensible en préambule
j'adresse mes sincères et chaleureuses
félicitations à l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs nouvellement
élus ou réélus dimanche dernier et je
vous souhaite la bienvenue au sein de
notre assemblée
j'ai aussi vous pouvez applaudir oui
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
j'ai aussi une pensée particulière pour
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ne
siégeront plus parmi nous soit parce
qu'ils ont décidé de se retirer de la
vie parlementaire soit parce qu'ils
n'ont pas été reconduits qu'ils soient
remerciés pour leur action constructive
dans tous les domaines et pour leur
participation à nos débats je tiens
également à rendre hommage à nos
collègues qui nous ont récemment quitté
et plus particulièrement au président
christian poncelet que beaucoup parmi
nous ont connus et appréciés président
du sénat de 1998 à 2008
ce grand serviteur de la république
ardent défenseur des territoires amour
passionné dessus du sien les vosges à
présider notre institution parlementaire
avec humanisme et générosité
dans un souci constant de rassembler et
de fédérer les bonnes volontés et sur
tous les bancs
[Applaudissements]
car vous le savez bien le sénat ces
règles de ses codes son ambiance plus
feutrée que celle de l'assemblée
nationale loin des turbulences du
palais-bourbon souvent soumis aux
soubresauts de l'actualité
la haute-assemblée reste pour moi un
espace de stabilité pour nos
institutions mais l'hocine le sénat ne
vit pas moins intensément le débat ils
fabriquent la loi de façon je dirais
plus subtil plus réaliste nous sommes
des parlementaires avant tout dans un
régime qui l'est de moins en moins
malgré l'article 24 de la constitution
mes collègues le savent je suis un
partisan acharné du dialogue constructif
de la co-construction que m'ont dit des
lois avec le gouvernement mais surtout
avec l'assemblée nationale avec les
députés qui ne comprennent pas toujours
ce que ce qui leur reste de pouvoir et
là dans le dialogue avec nous c'est une
manière de rendre le bicamérisme vivant
et notre pouvoir de contrôle plus
efficace
mais attention co-construction ne veut
pas dire consensus nous quel dommage
d'ailleurs d'affubler souvent ce mot de
cet adjectif
je suis pour un consensus d'action qui
demande beaucoup d'effort et de courage
le courage de la nuance disait albert
camus
il ya d'ailleurs une somme de talents de
compétences et expériences dans notre
assemblée qui peut apporter beaucoup à
la fabrication des lois le rôle du sénat
est plus que jamais en tant qu'assemblée
des territoires de fédérer les énergies
qui en émanent et vous l'incarnez
parfaitement chaire gérard larcher
sénateur et vous l'êtes bien sûr notre
position notre histoire personnelle
d'élu local régional ou départemental de
mer souvent le permet et l'autorisent
l'exigent même
et nous ne devons pas laisser l'archipel
français dont parle jérôme fourquet
explosé avec violence sans tenter de
relever les défis de notre temps défis
économiques et sociaux enjeux sociétaux
culturels environnementaux qui
s'empilent déjà sur la table du haut
commissaire au plan mon ami françois
bail parmi ceux-ci l'éducation la
formation plutôt long de la vie sont les
clés de notre avenir
j'ai pour ma part toujours pensé avec le
pédagogue antoine de la guerre rempli
que tous les enfants peuvent réussir et
qu'il représente une richesse pour notre
pays dont la démographie fait la force
un traumatisme comme le chômage devrait
être à terme obsolète la formation
l'adaptation aux nouveaux métiers
devraient être considérées comme des
activités indemniser le revenu de base
la solution universelle qui apporte une
sécurité à chacun dès sa naissance et
dans le même temps il convient d'agir
avec un maximum de vigueur sur le
terrain des inégalités de la pauvreté
terreau des chantres de la démagogie et
de la terre brûlée
beaucoup de nos concitoyens se sentant
abandonnés ont déserté les urnes
ils ont trouvé dans sur les ronds points
avec les gilet jaune un moyen de se
rendre visible un moyen de se faire
entendre notre système de représentation
a sans doute fait son temps il doit
évoluer
le référendum permettrait certes de
consulter sur des sujets cruciaux
il est une réponse mais pas la seule je
pense que le scrutin proportionnel est
également une piste envisagée
sérieusement
autre enjeu essentiel très présent la
santé
lakovic 19 est là pour nous le rappeler
la santé est un bien précieux que nous
avons tous peur de perdre notre système
est enviable et enviée
mais présente des lacunes que le ségur
tente de corriger dans sa gouvernance
l'accès aux soins et la reconnaissance
des personnels soignants
son financement est problématique car il
est trop liée au travail et le contrôle
des dépenses et prestations n'est pas
satisfaisant avec les actes inutiles et
redondant les fraudes aux prestations et
aux cotisations
ce sont les milliards qu'il nous faut
récupérer afin de financer ce qui est
devant nous l'autonomie des personnes
âgées et handicapées sans oublier la
lutte contre les maladies chroniques de
nos sociétés modernes où les prochains
virus qui nous guette à la liste
énumérés précédemment doit ajouter un
enjeu capital l'emploi et salle re
localisation mais aussi le partage des
richesses et des responsabilités
c'est la troisième voie plus nécessaire
que jamais que le général de gaulle
appelait de ses voeux pour que je le
cite
chaque homme trouve dans la société sa
place sa part sa dignité
enfin le défi climatique et écologique
est immense j'ai compris il ya bien
longtemps
grâce aux propos prémonitoires de jean
marie pelt professeur de biologie
végétale inspirateur de beaucoup
d'écologistes aujourd'hui il écrivait
des gens 1977 dans un livre l'homme
naturel et je le cite la situation est
sans précédent
quand donc avant nous l'humanité
avait-elle accumulé assez de pouvoirs et
de savoir pour anéantir toute vie sur la
terre et se détruire elle-même on a vu
la difficulté à mobiliser l'ensemble de
la planète sur ce sujet c'est donc à
l'europe de relever ce défi essentiel
grâce à l'action conjointe de la
chancelière merkel et du président
macron l'union européenne a pris un
tournant fédéral décisif à mes yeux avec
la mobilisation par le budget de l'union
de somme fabuleuse pour éviter
l'effondrement de notre économie et
faciliter la relance
cela traduit une mutation profonde de
l'esprit de l'union vers plus de
solidarité
c'est donc à l'europe de conduire avec
chaque état une politique concertée sur
la transition écologique et énergétique
elle doit également coordonner les
politiques concernant l'accueil des
migrants
la lutte sans relâche contre l'islamisme
radical et tous les séparatismes qui
menacent notre civilisation
enfin l'europe doit aider les états
reprendre le contrôle sur le pouvoir
tentaculaire et la buse yves
optimisation fiscale pratiquée à grande
échelle par les multinationales
à commencer par les gaffes à avec la
machine à accélérer le temps est en
marche et racé ici quelques pistes sur
des sujets qu'ils sont chers et vous me
pardonnerez mais me faut bien conclure
que deux fois ai-je entendu cette
sentence
jamais je ne ferais politique dans la
bouche de responsables d'acteurs de la
société
craignant de s'afficher ou de se
compromettre à leur propos paraphrasant
charles péguy on pourrait dire ils sont
les mains pures mais non pas demain
car qu'on l'admette ou non rien
n'échappe en effet à la politique
mon ami jean le camus et s'amuser même à
brandir un verre d'eau affirmant tout
est politique
même l'eau sujet d'actualité s'il en est
pour ma part je ne me suis jamais posé
la question de l'engagement politique
il allait de soi j'ai eu la chance de
naître dans une famille profondément
chrétienne où l'engagement le service le
partage l'accueil des autres étaient la
règle
la politique pour moi c'est donc donné
et aimé donner généreusement de son
temps de ses compétences et de son coeur
mais aussi aimé car il faut aimer
sincèrement les gens pour faire de la
politique
c'est ce qui me permet de continuer à en
faire passionnément
je vous souhaite donc mes chers
collègues de vivre aussi ce mandat qui
s'avère difficile je pensais qui
s'annonce difficile mais avec passion
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]